[Musique]
cette semaine aussi 17 une programmation
la plus éclectique possible en tout cas
on essaye donc plein de films à
l'affiché vacances scolaires obligent
je vous donne les titres rapidement
alita all inclusive une intime
conviction excellent à voir avec olivier
gourmet dans la peau de eric dupond
moretti
l'ordre des médecins la dernière folie
de claire darling
catherine deneuve bohemian rhapsody
qu'on a repris je le succès qui ne se
dément pas de ce film rage 2.0 pour les
enfants minuscule 2 et la chasse à
l'ours et je voulais surtout insisté sur
le festival ciné junior qui a lieu dans
nos salles pendant toute la durée du
mois de février même jusqu'à début mars
dont deux événements vous proposer cette
semaine pour les enfants
ainsi défilent ou avec un court métrage
un film de courts métrages capelle drôle
de planète dimanche matin à 10h30 et
surtout venez participer mardi prochain
à 16h 30 à l'atelier incrustation
incrustation pardon on vous expliquera
comment on fait des incrustations dans
les films à partir de fonds vers vous
avez déjà dû voir ça dans des
documentaires et c'est donc un
spécialiste de l'incrustation viendra
vous parler de cette technique d'effets
spéciaux au cinéma dans nos salles donc
mardi prochain
16h30 aussi 17 dans le cas du festival
si les juniors
[Musique]